take me through the day of september 11
2001 as you experienced it as you lived
it
september 11 2001 uh was a bright
beautiful sunny tuesday morning
as a late summer
there's a lot of folks who go to the
beaches in new jersey call it the short
summer everybody's left there for labor
day but it's still beautiful enough to
enjoy the weather
i left my house about 6 30 in the
morning
and uh my four and a half year old
daughter uh said to me daddy
which truck are you driving today um the
fire truck the oil truck or the boar's
head truck because i had three jobs at
the time
most new york city firefighters and
police officers ems we
don't make the most amount of money so
in order to live in that city you have
to you have to hustle and my wife stayed
at home raising the children
so
my daughter said oh she you should be
safe because you're on the oil truck i
said i told her i was going on an oil
truck that day so she said you should be
safe today daddy so i left and um
worked for this great company on the
north shore staten island quinlan fuel
uh very nice people treated me very well
and uh it was my first day back actually
for the winter season um
i usually get laid off a couple months
in the summer because things you know
too hot to need oil
so he took the truck started my route on
that day and uh
plane hit the tower
so initially i'm like it's probably some
silly leader jet pilot and he veered off
track to get a better picture for a
client and he hit the building
probably hit a
you know bad turbulence uh gust of wind
it's very windy down in that area
manhattan so that was my first thought
can we pause there for a second so 6 30
a.m you wake up you leave and then the
plane hits at
8 8 45 85 45 a.m yeah it's just
interesting how you phrase it so how did
you hear that a plane hit something
i um
i'm a big news radio guy uh news guy a
bit of a buff i've been that way since i
was a kid and i had the news radio on uh
the local new york radio station and as
i was driving the truck i heard uh
you know a emergency report this just in
aircraft has just struck the world trade
center
and uh where quinlan's is located it's
on the north rim of staten island which
is right on new york harbor and
you could see statue of liberty
you know a mile or two away in your
distance and then past that as
towers
so i just literally stopped the truck
and looked out and i saw the smoke so
there was smoke oh it was dark black
smoke it was just yeah i mean it was
burning fully at that point and uh did
you have fear of what the hell happened
or i was i was initially scared for
anybody involved uh i realized i said
there's there's going to be lots of
fatalities obviously depending on the
size of the aircraft and uh
you know uh the the business day there
had started probably at 8 8 30 so those
buildings should have been packed at
that moment so that was a thought across
my mind
but from our our uh being responder
perspective if you're off duty normally
you you do not go to a scene uh they
don't want you to because of
accountability and safety
uh the on-duty platoon will handle it
and if it's something
very horrific then they will have
something called a recall which is
any police firefighter or ems personnel
is obligated to go to their command
immediately
check in with
you know their command get their gear
and stand by and await orders for
deployment
uh or to remain in that command for
routine duties how often throughout
history have there been recalls i
believe the one prior to that was like
in the 1968 riots uh
possibly and then maybe in the 70s there
was another blackout in riots and i
remember my dad talking about it and he
actually always said just remember if
something bad's going down
don't just rush in you you you await the
recall or at the very least if there
isn't a recall you get to your firehouse
and because if you show up somewhere
there's a good chance that no one knows
you're there and now you
in your well-intended
uh movements you you get lost or trapped
or no one's looking for you so that's
the whole thing with you know checking
in and now
you're with a squad or you know group of
guys and
everyone knows you know hey there's nils
there's lex okay they're on you know
this team
so
i i said all right they're not gonna
need us it's probably gonna be a fifth
alarm and you know there'll be 250
firefighters there they'll handle it
it's going to be a bad day for those
guys but
you know our guys take on some heavy
stuff and they'll be fine
a few minutes later um the second plane
hit and i knew immediately i'm like
okay
uh we're under attack
so i just flew the truck back in i told
my boss
i have to go
he understood he knew something was way
wrong and i just was flying
at the time i actually had a yellow
volkswagen beetle kind of a goofy car to
be driving but i loved it so for people
who are just listening you're kind of a
big guy well yeah i could i definitely
need to lose about 50 pounds no i don't
mean in that way yeah your frame as my
hands as my beloved friend bobby adams
would say to me i i uh i was driving
around in a clown wagon and he also says
i have a waving waving hair dude waving
bye bye so thanks bobby
but yeah he's a great friend uh yeah so
i took the volkswagen and i flew in and
i was heading over to verrazano bridge
and uh hit the brooklyn queens
expressway
and my phone rang and my wife normally
doesn't uh curse or raise a voice and
she was yelling at me and she said don't
go in there go to your firehouse
well first she asked well she knew i was
on the way but she just wanted to know
where and um
i said i'm on i'm on the curve which is
65th street on the brooklyn queens
expressway called dead man's curve we we
actually used to do a lot of car wrecks
up there
and i was hitting that curve pretty fast
and then right around the curve is the
exit to the firehouse and i had to
decide well am i driving right in to the
battery tunnel to the city
or am i going to the firehouse and then
i said but i have no gear i
i'm going to be ineffective how do i
show up with no gear no protection no
you know so
she said do what your dad would
follow the recall go to the firehouse i
said hung up the phones i love you gotta
go
and i did i went to the firehouse and
i'm glad i listened to her i had my
father ringing in my ears my dad
beautiful guy he's uh 82 in 34 years in
new york city fire department
he uh
he came down end stage non-hudson's
lymphoma uh he's 38
back in uh
going on 39 1978.
and uh this guy
he uh
he's my hero he um
he was going to die they sent him home
they said you there's really not much we
can do go get your affairs and
he says but doc i have three young kids
and and uh
she she called a couple hours later she
said um i got in touch with sloane
kettering and now
they have a new uh new drug we want you
to be a test pilot
and she's he said hey doc i'm a he's got
a heavy brooklyn accent i'm a fireman
i'm a fireman i'm not a pilot
and uh
so she said no no we want you to try
this drug out and it's if it works we
might have some success but if not he
says yeah i'm gonna die so let's do it
so uh every
every two weeks
for four years
he'd uh he'd go for treatment
but uh he was assigned to a desk job
after that after the
the cancer tumor removal and you know
the heavy treatments
and he'd get up every morning four
o'clock in the morning and he'd uh he'd
walk down to the train station in staten
island take the train and then he'd uh
take the ferry across the harbor
and he'd get off looking at the towers
and then he'd take a subway into
brooklyn
and on every other thursday he'd leave
at noon
and do the same exact reverse route and
he'd get to the cancer center
and uh my mom would meet him
and he'd get his infusion and within two
hours he'd be violently ill for a
few days really badly ill
and i just remember um
yeah he's 10 years i was 10 years old
and
he just had to have the room talking
down and he he'd be so sick and i just
go in and wipe the vomit
on his face
just try to give him a little water but
he couldn't take it down because he'd
throw it up
and uh
maybe on saturday he started
coming around a little bit
drink down a little bit of tea and on
sunday morning he put his robe on he
mom and make him
black coffee and toast
he'd sit up
watch the news watch the game and then
monday morning he'd go back to work he
did that for four years
and uh he's 82 and he's still
here
uh you said that your dad's a man of a
few words but when he talks they're
profound so what what words were ringing
in your ear when you were driving i just
always remember them saying kid they
give the recall you go to the firehouse
you don't go where you think you should
you go to the firehouse you follow your
orders so do the smart thing do your job
yes sir and every time we hang up the
phone it's firemen talk
he'd say i love you keep low
my dad couldn't tell me he loved me
until um
i told him when
i first got on a fire department i was
22 and my dad grew up in a tough
household my grandad was a good man but
a tormented man he
he was sent away from home at 12 years
old
um he was in from denmark and i'm named
after him grandpa nils
and uh i think his demons
took up a large part of his life his his
anger his whatever it was his fear i i
we got the sense that maybe when he was
a child he was an apprentice baker you
know living
with strangers working for them and we
we think maybe he was abused and that's
why he took it out of my my dad and my
grandma my aunts but um
they uh they made it up to each other at
the end of my grandad's life my granddad
turned out to be the best grandfather
ever he i think he tried to heal and
heal everyone by his change of behavior
so
he's proof that uh you can't change you
can improve if you work on it but i know
i'm going off track here but uh but you
were man enough and you're you said in
your 20s to tell you my dad yeah
i got on a job uh he said i had to go
kid how was the tour we called tour of
duty so i thought it was great it was
great i love it
and he goes we just remember you keep
low you always keep low and keep low
means you stay down below the flames you
know for room flash is over and it's
it's burning you if you stay up high
you're gonna get burned badly but if you
get down on your belly and you crawl
you'll get out
so he'd always say that when you hang up
the phone and i said well i love you pop
and he says uh well thanks kid
i said well you can say it too and uh
oh nice he pressured him and he did and
he said it and now every time we talk he
says it so you know
you know they talk about masculinity and
whatnot and uh my dad is one of those
tough tough guys with a soft edge and
that's that's how he brought me up um
you know to be a protector i hate
bullies i was bullied really badly as a
kid and
i really hated it and and now i i find
myself sometimes throwing myself into
situations to protect
people that are being you know
violated and hurt and uh
i just can't walk away from it but
that's my dad my dad was that you know
just a great guy but anyway yeah just to
listen to you therefore see you you
probably want to rush right to the
to the towers but you went yeah so
anyway i got i i did i listened to him i
listened to my wife i went to the
firehouse and it was really strange it
was eerie because um
the computer dispatch system was was
still beeping
which meant it sent a dispatch and
the truck received it ladder 114 my my
truck company received it and they left
they were gone
so there was this beautiful old building
built in the 1880s with a spiral
staircase
just a narrow old brick garage
and it was empty
and i just heard the computer chirping
and i looked down on a ticket and i said
ladder 114 respond the vessel west world
trade center aircraft into building
and i said oh god i just hope they're
not on a death ride because this this
now was two
towers
and uh they were burning they were free
burning and and i knew this was really
really bad
and uh i got on the phone and i called
command right away i called the 40th
battalion and i you know chiefs chief's
aide just said look you know get 12 guys
sign them in
to the journal there's a journal of
daily events every everything that takes
place in the firehouse 24 7 has to be
logged
and i locked myself as coming in
reporting for reporting for duty um and
as the guys came in i logged them in and
then uh
one of our lieutenants took command
we grabbed up a bunch of gear and they
basically told us get 12 guys get a city
bus
and get down to the batter the battery
tunnel they they said would probably be
closed there was threats it was going to
be blown up
to get to the brooklyn bridge
and uh
so we did we got a city bus we flagged
it down and the bus driver said i'm
sorry i can't give you the bus i will
drive you and he took us and we stopped
at engine 201 which is
just about a quarter mile down the road
from us uh
that's our affiliated engine company and
my uh my my childhood best friend uh
here johnny uh shard was
he was a sign there and he was on shift
and uh
and they went through the tunnel
we picked up those guys the off-duty
guys from 201 and then we kept going
down 4th avenue and we picked up 239's
crew
and then we hightailed it down the
bridge and um
there's a lot of traffic there's a lot
of people
fleeing coming over the bridge and waves
so it affected uh
the inbound
what was the mood like uh
it was somber because just prior to
getting on the bus the uh
first tower went down
so we we we figured that
i heard 114 uh my lieutenant dennis
oberg
i heard him on the radio and he uh
he said 114
manhattan we're on your frequency what's
you know what do you need us and they
said uh
tally ho which is our nickname tallyho
responding to vessel west to the command
post
and uh receive your orders
and i heard dennis take tallyho 10-4
and uh dennis
a little while after that
they were proceeding to go into
i believe it was i get this mixed up and
i'm sorry i should know this by the back
of my hand but sometimes it's just such
a
haze but
the second tower hit was the first one
to go down and um they were heading over
to go in it and all of a sudden he
looked up and he saw like what he
thought to be disintegration and he
turned the guys around he said run just
run don't look back don't look up go
they sprinted as fast as they could
and uh they dove under a fire truck
and the guys that were sprinting behind
them 40 feet away were
underneath the pile that was 10 stories
deep they they were killed
and just
further into that pile was his rookie
son
who dennis's rookie son who was working
in ladder 105 which was my first command
on the department
i worked for
proudly served for three years
and just beside them was my childhood
best friend john shard and his uh
his crew from 201 and uh
they they were all
killed and the strange irony to um to
that is that
dennis dennis's son dennis jr was
working underneath the uh
under the wing of a senior man as we say
senior man this guy with a lot of
experience and he'll uh
to watch over you make sure you don't
you know veer off like i hear awful lot
talking and uh
you don't veer off and you get yourself
hurt
in the morning of 1993 bombing
henry miller was my senior man
and i was the young guy under his wing
and he protected
me and toward the end of the day he
looked around he said kid
it's a bad day
he said
they didn't do it right they blew it up
in the middle
[Music]
if they did it in a corner
they would have dropped this building
half mile down to canal street
but don't kid yourself they'll be back
and they'll do it and they'll do it
right next time
and it's so strange and so prophetic
because
he was there with him he died with
dennis he knew it and like 1994 we had a
training manual with a picture of the
towers with a target
and this is not
not a matter of if but a matter of when
be prepared
that's one thing it was like people knew
right
and we didn't stop it
and uh
so we got off the bus
but just prior to that coming over the
bridges the second tower was gone now
and we're just destroyed because we're
like our guys are there they're all in
there now we're feeling like cowards
because we got there late
and
initially we're thinking there's 500
guys that are gone because it was a 10th
alarm assignment which means
50 60 fire trucks
uh five to six guys per you know you're
looking at
at least you know it was even more a
tenth alarm plus multiple alarms on top
of it there was a dispatch basically
equivalent of five to six hundred
firefighters
we figured oh they're all they're all in
there all gone all the police officers
port authority police nypd police
court officers just up the street from
the courts
transit cops from
the train tunnels like just you know we
knew everybody was going and uh now
they're gone
so you what you saw what were we looking
at what did it look like so you saw
rubble and then you knew
that many that 105 and 201 many of those
guys are in the
they're dead
yeah what and we thought
was in there too we didn't realize at
that point we didn't even realize that
they had gotten under that truck we
thought they were all gone but yeah it
looked like like it looked like
it looked like a movie scene with just
end of the earth destruction these just
massive piles of
intertwined steel what was left of the
steel and and you know there was no
cement it was all just dust and
it was just a burning pile of dust and
concrete and plastic and it was just
everything was just pulverized and it
was it was truly hard to
mentally compute that like it was like
what
and then there was just fighter jets a
couple fire just just circling and and
you just heard flying by over your head
i mean you'd literally see the guy
banking the turn around the brooklyn
bridge and just coming back and i'm like
holy shoot we're under attack
and we we couldn't really get concrete
intel as to what exactly we knew planes
but then we kept hearing there was
multiple devices there was devices in a
battery tunnel and there was devices on
the george washington bridge and in the
subways and it was just it was just
chaos it was i mean we kept it together
obviously because that's kind of we try
that's what we do
but the
the just constant barrage of different
reports it was like holy shoot
and then as we were being deployed it
was a little frustrating but they were
trying to take command and send us in
groups now because they realize we have
to start searching this there's
you could hear the the alarms on the on
the scott air mass the packs we wear to
go into the building it has a motion
alarm and if you stop moving for 30
seconds it just sounds like this whining
you know
this screaming bell like it just keeps
going and going
and you could hear multiple units of
those going off and you're like
wait a minute there's guys with those
like where are they
and it's emanating from underneath the
pile and
wow you know it was it was just surreal
and um
truly like
like like a war zone you know i mean i
was a soldier in reserves and i never
saw combat and i would never claim that
i did but
you know we trained we trained for a lot
of situations and we trained in you know
real life atmospheres and whatnot and
this was just beyond that by leaps and
bounds it was it was bizarre
did you see the towers collapse as we
were coming over the bridge the first
one
we were as we were deploying from the
firehouse we had a television and i saw
it go down
and it just
it's just like and you know we were so
involved in getting gear together and
getting okay you know teams set up and
okay you're going to be with these two
guys and these
and i just yelled at the guys and
they're looking at me i dropped to my
knees and i started praying like what
what the hell's wrong i said
i couldn't even say it's like
114 they're in there and and they're
like what i said the tower's gone
and all you saw on the tv was just this
pile of dust and
i guess because they didn't see it going
down i probably thought i
truly lost it and and
then
then the realization came was like oh
wow the tower's down so now it was like
wow this is really on so we we just took
off and got that boss and uh
so if you thought many of the guys in
114 were dead
if you thought that did you think you're
going to die i mean if you're rushing
into the
towards the rubble
i as crazy as it sounds i never thought
that the other tower would go down i
said okay maybe some freak chance that
one went down
but no the other one's not gonna go like
they're built so strong you know i was
in those towers so many times and i ate
dinner up in the top four restaurant
windows on the world and i'm saying
nah there's no way like like how the
hell did this one happen
but i i was having a hard time mentally
processing that the building was gone
and
and and believe me if if you don't have
fear in this industry and you know
police fire military then you're kidding
yourself
or you're a danger to everyone i don't
care who it is as tough as they are this
and that everybody has a certain level
of fear with doing this and i don't care
how long you do it
there's always that chance of something
going bad and and
everyone who does it has that certain
amount of fear
but at that point it was such a feeling
of disbelief
that fear wasn't even kicking in it was
just like what the hell just happened
and
i honestly think it was almost like a
shock and and it just stayed that whole
day um so the building is
before collapses is burning it's just
burning i mean upper floors this you
know up in the 78th up to the 80s and
then
it's you know there's the way that the
cut was when the plane it wasn't just
straight across it was you know from the
78th then you know on up to maybe the
86th and
you know um then
the jet fuel had come down and was
burning down and there was people on the
on the ground who were
doused with
jet fuel that was already burning and
they were lit on fire on the ground it
was it was just insane how
vast the destruction path was the
firefighter
what are you supposed to do with that
scale of fire
i i think the first bosses in the first
chiefs
were just going to do their best to get
as we we get hose lines what our whole
theory is our tactics is to get water at
the fire at the base of the fire and get
the truck company which is the ladder
company they're the guys who break the
doors down put ladders up this and that
to get them to where the life is most
expected and get them out of there
so i think the chiefs tactics at that
point was let me get multiple engine
companies let me get four five six hose
lines fighting this fire this massive
fire and let me get 15 20 truck
companies up there just yolking people
out of there yeah but you got to go up
the stairs everything's not working yeah
guys had to walk up 80 80 90 100 flights
of stairs
and there's audio of
of
officers and firefighters speaking to
each other on the radio channels and
unfortunately at that point in time we
had very very bad communication system
we've been fighting for years to get
radios that work properly we couldn't
because it was a lot of money
we fought for years to get the full
bunker firefighting suits which is the
pants and the coat we used to have just
coats and these roll up rubber boots and
guys were burning to death and we had to
fight and unfortunately we lost three
guys in one vicious vicious fire in 1994
and then they finally said enough's
enough give these guys the gear
so
it's a strange phenomenon in the first
responder world and in the military
world
it's really one of the most important
things that takes place in society the
most pertinent
organizations and we can't get the
funding we need it's crazy they'll throw
money at every nonsensical thing but
when it comes to
gear equipment protective equipment
trucks this
couldn't get it
just all the ways you could take care of
people i saw
in since 9 11 the wars in the middle
east have cost america over six trillion
dollars
and
the amount of that money that was spent
on
the soldiers
in this case the first responders is
minimal compared to it yeah almost
nothing they they like stay closed down
i believe it's either seven or eight
in
may of
they closed down nine fire houses in new
york city for budget reasons
we hadn't even finished cleaning up the
world trade center site and they slashed
the budget
and
still to this day
have not reopened those fire houses
there's a million more people now living
in new york city than there were in
2001.
and the fire protection is is way less
than it was and it's it's a sin
it's really a sin
you